to me this is one of the coolest things
i've ever read so here you are that the
you know the height of the the the scene
and you befriend a fellow model patty
hanson who is dating keith richards
and so you say this sounds so exciting
to me because to me keith richards is
one of the greatest the coolest ever
like the coolest guy right now more cold
than than you really even no and so
you're hanging out with the stones
and keith richards you describe a scene
where you're on an airplane
and keith is turning to you and saying
hey i just wrote a song tell me what you
think of it you must have been hearing
songs like you know ruby tuesday or
sympathy for the devil because he was
coming up with riffs left and right at
that point right it was amazing actually
we were on the concord together and then
when we got in the limousine gives me
the chills yeah he he put on you know
before it was like up top there or
whatever it is and you know i'm
listening and he's going you know
you got ears you know listen to this and
that and other it was just so cool and
he was so and he is so talented and such
a great writer and everything and just
to see them in love and i remember patti
you know we went down to the bathroom
afterwards and she said beverly this is
the one i'm like what do you mean this
is the one we're just hanging out with
the guy she said no i'm going to get
married i'm going to have children with
him i'm like whoa whoa let's slow down
honey go slow up now you're losing
oxygen you know
we're having fun here but don't you know
but and they were and they were and they
did and it's wonderful beverly isn't it
the most intoxicating to be hanging out
with a rock so who's sitting there
creating some of the world's greatest
music i cannot tell you was it great
stuff like were you listening and were
you
in a way it's the greatest seduction for
for a man to seduce a woman isn't it
well i i you know i've been around it
because remember you know one of the
husbands uh
got reggae music to america and so i was
around bob marley and everything and
i've kind of been around a lot of
musicians and all of that and so what
was marley like
unbelievable what is unbelievable
unbelievable first of all he was so
handsome good looking dude and just very
oh my god now that's when i regret not
well anyway
why didn't you sleep with him i don't
know what were you thinking just too
much for me it was just he he blew your
mind yeah he really did and just you
know his energy and what he was talking
about in his songwriting and you know
and all of that and the pot thing was so
much of his culture like was he
constantly stoned and smoking and did he
have the best weed
he was just the coolest of the cool you
know
and these guys can have anything they
want and you're probably aware of that
too in a way it's a game too you're like
you know what i'm just not going to give
it up so easy for some of these guys
because they can have anybody and
they're you know they're just going to
go on to the next one and the next one
in the next one you know you know i just
like to appreciate them for you know
what they are who what they have to
offer you know it's not really like a
relationship thing for me i can't get
off this plane with keith richards so
when he's sitting there do you do you
remember any one song where he turned to
you and said hey what do you think of
this riff and then it was like you know
i don't know satisfaction or something
do you remember any particular one i
don't but i do remember he did a solo
album that was the expense of winos
right yeah yeah yeah it was i dig that
album actually he's really really really
talented really cool guys do you think
he was playing those songs for you
showing off and knowing he was no you
think it was just like he was really
curious write that no he was really
curious because he
he knew i had been around you know a lot
of people in the music industry and also
i'm black and i'm cool right and he knew
i had ears you know
i think they can sense whether you know
somebody is cool and they have ears and
whatever and i did i do have ears is
being cooled hard in other words i was
never a cool guy i i don't know how to
be cool i don't know how to be
comfortable in a crowd i don't know how
to hang what does it mean yeah how do
you do all of that well i think that you
you you don't say very much and and
that's the secret no you have hit it
yeah i talk too [ __ ] much
i could never be cool you have to be
like an observer you know it's almost
like andy warhol he never spoke it was
so weird i mean he even called me up one
day and he didn't say it didn't say
anything that's the coolest move i mean
really